We carried out about 18 months of research for the state National geographic drama
We had a team of researchers based in Britain working internationally
There's a huge amount of material on social Media. There's a huge amount of video material posted by the islamic State
there
Scarily Proficient and
Everything we've done in the drama stands on the shoulders of that research
Although the characters are kind of composites of a number of real people
Everything you see in the drama actually takes place
grows out of the research that we've carried out so although it goes under the banner of
A fictional drama because the characters are fictional
Every event you see depicted within it really took place
I think we've always felt that in an ideal world the show would be an entity antidote to simplistic thought so people could
Do as I said trying a different?
Understanding a deeper understanding of what might motivate young people to travel to Syria. I think part of the problem
Is there's a very unsophisticated?
view of the kind of guys from this country and elsewhere in the world who traveled to syria and around about
2014-2015 there's a tendency to just say well. They're clearly all insane
Joining some kind of death cult in the drama
We show that people go out for all different types of reasons
And it's not as simple as people might think that it's a far more complex
Situation and hopefully the drama gets inside in a way that documentaries can't drama is always engaged
with these difficult forces within society and and the state is just another example of that kind of
Attempt the islamic state has been responsible for a number of appalling atrocities
I don't think we do a service to the families of those who've suffered or to those who've been caught up in their bombing
outrages and survived with horrific injuries by simply suggesting
That the people involved in this organization are insane. It's our job as dramatists to hold a mirror up to society and to
Treat with these sometimes extremely difficult got subjects that are of current
importance and
I suppose our
objective here in trying to examine this this event which needs to be happening in in our world at the moment is to try to
Take a more
Nuanced view of it to get a little bit beyond the depiction of these people as insane or pSychotic
Because how are we ever going to combat it if we don't properly understand it